The last question is,
what happens when you want to update?
Say Heartbleed comes out or you got
a new version of your app, what then?
Obviously, we want to update our
containers to protect our data or
to get new code out in front of users,
but
it would be risky to roll
those changes out all at once.
So instead we use queued CTO rollout.
Let's walk through an example.
In this example we're going to be
updating our Pods to a new version.
So we have a service with three
replicated pods, after issuing
the queued CTO roll out command for
v2 of our app, one comes online.
Then our server starts
routing traffic to it.
So we have both v1 and
v2 getting traffic at the same time.
Next we stop routing traffic
to one of the old pods, and
then we get rid of it entirely.
At this point the cycle continues, all
the way through till we get our desired
three replicas back, at which point we
have three versions of app v2 running.
That's pretty cool.
Let's have Kelsey show
us this in practice.